it took years and years of women
marching and fighting to get equality it
wasn't until a little over a hundred
years ago Anna Navaro Anna Navaro who
lives here in the Free State of Florida
and constantly rails against all of our
freedoms uh and just spouts complete and
utter nonsense every day on The View uh
this this one's a true gem uh about
how America is just as racist as always
enjoy well there's so many parts of of
that aspect of the racism thing that
bothers me it bothers me because she's
not stupid she's not
ignorant uh she's not racist but she's
pandering to a base she reminds me of a
human version of those wind socks that
you see in front of use car dealerships
she just she will bend whichever way the
wind blows and she you know very
casually said about uh all men are
created equal that did not include uh
African-Americans did not include women
she said we fixed it along the way as if
it was a typo that they said you know
what let me fix that let me cross that
out and put no it took a civil war
700,000 almost Americans died in that
Civil War you know what the equivalent
of 700,000 Americans are today almost 7
million Americans that would be the
equivalent today it took years and years
of women marching and fighting to get
equality it wasn't until a little over a
100 years ago that the 18th amendment
was ratified so for her to casually
you're making the reverse point you ding
back the people that fought for equality
the people who were writing the
documents as I always say Thomas
Jefferson George Washington the other
Founders many of them were writing the
documents that were ultimately going to
free the slaves we had a women's
suffrage movement that allowed
ultimately women to be able to vote and
everything else and black people got the
right to vote and all of the things that
led us to equ quality and then we got
there but you people said that's not
good enough so let's bring a whole bunch
of racism back and now it is it is your
functioning ethos that you push on us
every day and now you judge everyone's
decisions on whether they agree with you
when you look at someone only as to
whether they are black or brown or
sometimes whether they're just a
chick